para os santanenses isto deve ser
natural mas vou tentar
alê agora obrigado a contar histórias
contar histórias começa em santo mé
desta maneira e por que começa a contar
histórias
comecei a contar histórias por um mero
acontecimento uma mera coincidência
como se um mais um fosso e 211 mais um
fosse um a história e eu ea história não
sei se encontra a história outra
história sem encontrar o homem
comecei a ouvir contar histórias desde
criança por ter nascido fora de são tomé
passei nem faz se ouvir em são tomé em
santo andré em santo andré em santo
andré e depois começou a ver quando
fomos independentes quando fomos
independente quando fomos dependente
essa quantidade de informações foram
crescendo na minha cabeça e eu sonhando
como será a ação também teve a sorte ea
graça de conhecê-la pelo ar em 75 quando
cheguei o avião aterra eo meu pai
apresentou uma cidade lá no cimo quando
chegou ao hotel o hospital quartel do
lado o sim no bahia da chave no país
esta é a cidade para uma criança que
vinha de uma capital como madri o mas o
meu espanto foi quando meu pai parou
aqui enfrenta o náutico disse
esta é a nossa casa
uma vivenda a spprev no 9º andar uma
caixa de como você queria mas fazer o
quê
no natal daquele ano o meu pai diz vai
passar as férias na casa da avó no
reboque e um dia uma senhora que o céu
de suely mãe terezinha conta as
histórias e 12 mil que estava no quintal
que era mais perto porque nós perguntou
mãe terezinha
essa história me ouviam contra a minha
avó avô do avô contou sua história a mãe
terezinha sim em quem votou a favor da
volta a voz de mãe terezinha foi também
a bola
o avô da volta volta volta a mãe
terezinha conta essa história
sim e quem contou o avô do avô do avô do
avô do avô da mãe terezinha foi também
avô dela aí e quem contou a volta a
volta avô do avô da volta a volta avó e
da mãe terezinha o que ela respondeu
isto para dizer que nós estamos nesse
preciso momento diante de um grande
desafio
nós eu sempre ouvi dizer eu creio que o
adágio universal é preciso conhecer o
passado para entender por exemplo e
melhorar o futuro o que o futuro
acontece aqui e agora efe - passou por
exemplo acontecer no futuro o futuro
aconteceu hoje um bocado nas dúvidas nas
indefinições na busca da solução do
material técnico do dólar estava a
acontecer futurismo neste momento que é
o presente deixou de ser o futuro que
está acontecendo e se nos remetemos para
o passado para nos entendermos e
saberemos quem não somos nós aprendemos
uma coisa o homem inventou foguetões
para ir à lua e vitor armas que destrói
quase 300 e tal mil pessoas numa cidade
e com as donas milhões noutra num facto
único dia de 45 disse pimenta uma coisa
chamada bomba atômica
matam-se espaço de três horas tanta
gente tanta gente tanta gente como nunca
se viu o homem que destroem dessa
maneira também consegue construir carlos
telemóveis fantásticas casas fantásticos
feliz mas há uma coisa que o homem
inventou a mais perigosa todas a palavra
e eu descobri isso contando histórias
ao contar histórias quando me lançar um
desafio de fazer uma imprópria perguntar
porque é que eu conto histórias
o que me levou a contar histórias
fístula três semanas a perguntar até que
de repente ter fechados
eu acabei por descobrir ressentimento e
o conto histórias desde 1994 praia pra
completar complementar a minha
actividade e ator
contudo desde 1994 em escolas e
universidades em restaurante noturnos
a televisão conta e faço só há três
semanas que o descobrir por que conta
histórias eu jardim acho até a 15 me
trazia eu acho
depois do vídeo anterior dos oradores
ver a história contada pelos bailarinos
agora aqui e hoje eu tenho certeza eu
conto histórias para conhecer a mim
através dos outros senão vejamos
consciência e repararmos que nós vivemos
nesta coisa chamada terra
infelizmente com violência infelizmente
sem voz
infelizmente não sei identidade lo
a palavra é o que nos une contando a
história dos outros ea nossa história
acabamos descobrindo que a diferença
neste mundo é curioso é que o tornará
belo é que faz único é que nos fazem
crescer o outro em nós e nós e nos
outros eles fazer aquilo que nós somos
contaram histórias nos humanizamos
tornar um jeito podemos ouvir o outro z
odeio sem tiros outro dizer eu que odeia
o deles aceitar a palavra eu poderei
transformá-la em amor e com isso criar
contas e nessa fonte que a comunidade
que irá amor criador e nada criar paixão
que a cunhada
para exemplificar os isso vou contar nos
1 só é esse o tempo mesmo permiter mas
outra é uma história que conto muito
porque eu acho exemplar é um conto
popular português chamada a tia miséria
dizer que é muito muito muito tempo
no momento além de já vi uma senhora que
não tinha nada a única coisa que ela
consiga janela era uma figueira que ela
tenha plantado
ela adorava os filhos daquela figueira a
droga tanto tanto tanto tanto que não
como um fim mas os putos da aldeia o pt
da casa da tia miséria o que ele mais
gostava
iam roubavam ea tia miséria seria
castigo de deus não se rouba filho não
se rouba deus castiga miséria criança
isso não tem que roubar toys quem cedo
começa a faltar nunca direita e se for
um dia de inverno
para quem conhece aqueles velhos
horríveis que faz frio vento neve chuva
aquele estava na cama dormir quando de
repente arremata a porta ela acorda vai
até a porta abre em frente dela tava
homem comum correio ou ordenar e
apresentá-la entre entre o homem entrou
entraram ea terceira pessoa porque a
mulher muito rápido muito rápido lei
corajoso com as mulheres dos santos foi
até o quarto e meteu a mão no baú e um
pedaço de pão duro que ela guardava as
últimas emergências foi a correr e
entregou o homem diz coma o homem
começou a comer o pão que quer dizer
como era muito ágil no pensamento pensou
que paulo seco como se ele tem fui a
correr enfrentou o frio o vento granizo
a trovoada meu foi proposto a derrubada
da água foi a correr quando entra na
sala um calor envolve no corpo aquele
calor entre o homem o jarro homem bebeu
água e alicia cansado não é um pouco que
a miséria então vá durma cada um do seu
lado porque a miséria era uma mulher de
respeito
no dia seguinte de manhã malu sol raia a
tmz também o homem também estava de pé
já está de pé
já cíntia nigéria após folha comida que
já não há mais para agradecer a sua
bondade hospitalizado e vou conceder a
graça de um desejo o desejo assim pessoa
que quiser que o conselho não precisa eu
tenho tudo até quando os cachorros vivem
e roubar os fios
eu até gosto
chez pedissem gostaria mais mas que não
fazem companhia ela tem tudo que eu
preciso
que miséria pensa o que quiser que eu
concedo mas ele tem tudo que ele séria
olhem para mim não reconheça não ter
razão
ninguém nunca viu meu rosto eu sou mais
poderoso que o sol
vocês já repararam ninguém nunca olha eu
sou diferente
olhamos um para baixo pelo forte dizem
que por detrás do sol quem conseguir
olhar está cara de deus e eu tenho a
dizer que eu nunca tinha visto eu disse
não estou bem não por ter razão eu sou
deus adeus não é a deus eu sou deus a
deus sim pois deus diga peça o que
quiser que o conselho não precisa nada
senhor deus quer dizer isso deus faz
porque eu quiser também mas eu não
preciso
ela era muito rápida e rapidamente
pensou
desta maneira vou pedir uma coisa
simples ele como pensa que deus conserve
muesc graça vai embora feliz e eu feliz
fico já sei que opere com a dos pontos
de roubar o figo não deixam da figueira
sem deixar de dizer não eu faço o que
você quiser euromilhões projeto pop um
palácio amarelo ou vermelho
quero que o marido novo na queda do
dólar depois mudava não quero que deus
concedeu e foi embora
naquela época de figos os pilotos foram
para o filho já tinha miséria e até
mesmo em cima da figueira da roche
o filho do ditador da europa se for 5º
atirar figos chico tirarmos público é
baixo pediam chico olha pra mim sim
a proteína hotel este pequenino então eu
penso grande ou pequeno porque é
democracia quem tem cima distribuir quem
também baixo como cala
após a copa e chico na sua distribuição
democrática os putos avisaram chico vem
aqui e dizer vamos engrossar moura
oshika osmar chico chico tentou mexer da
figueira
para surpresa dele se todos ele não
conseguir destinar figueira tinha
miséria foi feito explicou chico é
feiticeira campos ocorreu na aldeia toda
impedir que eles é que temos e se não
sair enquanto eu não quiser tanto
pediram que ela aceitou
mas naquele verão a tia miséria estava a
dormir quando de repente alguém bata à
porta ela vai ver a porta em frente dela
tá bom é comum normal corrente ordinário
até miséria
o homem sim sim sim sim da miséria
apareceu aqui tem pressa vamos embora
não querem não quero e não ter era muito
rápida
eles levaram os conselhos uma graça de
um desejo um desejo e mais nenhum também
também também ok você quer um filho da
figueira que nunca comi támbém para que
não digam que a morte é má
vou conceder a graça de um figo som
bora lá subiram à figueira e sofia
oliveira não aqui
agora o que não tinha mais nenhum também
fizera carro pelas vias da dúvida com o
meu filho
a moto foi deixando quando chegou no
último degrau no último ramo
vamos embora a miséria e tentou saltar a
moto não sei da figueira ea miséria é
bem feito e bem feito é feita a mim não
me leva a nada
pois mas infelizmente a morte também faz
parte da vida
ela tem que existir para que a vida
exista todo mundo e ninguém morria
depois de muito insistir em muita gente
efeito do quintal da miséria pedindo que
ela disse basta cheirar morta apareceu
um homem comum correto ordinário entre
as pessoas foi ter com a tia miséria
falou com ela concordou o homem foi
embora ea camiseta aproximou do sul
a árvore da figueira eles a moto pode
vestir que o autor isso e dizem que
desde aquele dia
até hoje a morte existe mas a miséria
também andam de mãos dadas
e aqui começa a verdadeira história
o motivo por que conta histórias se a
miséria flores foi esperta conseguiu
fintar a moto nós também se fomos
espertos
conseguimos fintar a miséria é apenas
temos consciência de uma coisa temos que
ser protagonistas da nossa história
temos que ser ator
os ativos do nosso processo temos um
princípio um meio e um fim como dizia a
lei
se deixamos que os pais costumam nossa
casa nós estamos a ser atores passivo da
nossa existência
nós estamos a viver estamos a sobreviver
e como diz a pouco estamos numa fase
charneira estamos a mudar uma fase
estamos numa fase de mudança na
sociedade tanto - estamos num processo
de transformação
quando o pessoal do tempo falhou e
futurismo a primeira reação foi o
futurismo e são também com tantos
problemas que temos não estão construir
o futuro aceitando o presente conhecendo
o passado
este poema teve que apareceram são
problemas que temos que enfrentar todos
os dias como a lei disse no início há
barreiras se desistirmos paramos se
pararmos estagnamos vemos sempre no
presente não avançamos e estamos nos
passado enfrentamos um presente para
desafiar o futuro
estamos a caminhar para
franco e ao caminhão para frente
construímos a construímos nos conhecemos
alguns conhecemos e amamos e os amargos
vivemos porque temos uma única obrigação
na terra sermos felizes
e para ser feliz temos que chamar mais
atenção o amor próprio tenha sua
armadilha
dizem que ela é cega e anda de mãos
dadas com a loucura há muito tempo com
deus fez o mundo fez o que todo mundo
os meads os bens exceto e depois no meio
de uma brincadeira com a loucura
passou-se nome da raiva agarrou numa
forquilha que espetando assim à toa a
toa sem querer com a forquilha acertou
nos olhos do amor e era co do amor ficou
cego mas o amor tudo perdoa eles a
partir de hoje passa as tuas serão meus
olhos da mata sua mão
dizem que desde que o dia até hoje o
amor é cega e anda de mãos dadas com a
loucura gay
obrigado